i wanted to play a little game with you
oh my gosh
yes okay ready here we go
okay so is it true or false that you
stole your mother's range rover and then
drove it somewhere hmm so is the range
rover story true
so yeah that is true um
i stole my mom's range rover in the
not the middle of the night it might
have been like nine or ten but she was
already asleep
and i snuck out i stuffed my bed with
pillows i just knew i was wiser than
anybody else stole the car i went to a
party at a hotel
and i parked my car yada yada um
valet comes knocking on the door and
they're like excuse me
there's this car that's on fire and
your car is next to it and it's burning
half of it so apparently someone was
cheating on their husband the husband
came and lit
their the wife's car on fire and i
didn't value my car
because i couldn't afford valet at the
time i was 16.
and i had my keys so they couldn't move
my car and half of
the range rover caught on fire and i was
just so scared and i
drove home with literally half there's
like rubber you know around the windows
like
it's all dripping down it's like i was
drivable but it was
it was the navy blue range rover and it
literally changed color on one side
because of the heat and it was
so bad and this is why you don't sneak
out and you don't lie because you're
gonna get caught
and every time i lied i got caught
i just really enjoyed that story because
that's the exact type of stuff
i did too i remember one night i had to
get to a new year's eve party
so badly we were on the sunset strip
and i my car got locked in a parking lot
like a
full big gate like someone had just shut
it
and locked it and i was like you know
what i i'm just gonna drive
through it and so i kept ramming into
and it sort of went up
instead of like blowing open and then it
was like halfway and then i just kept
going back and forth and running to it
and then at some point it was like a
movie set like
all these people were on sunset strip
all the rockers like
celebrating new year's eve and they were
cheering me on like it was
almost famous movie like super cameron
crow i was like billy crudup
like i'm a golden god you know like
jumping into the pool it was totally
that moment
and those are the moments where i just
want like my kid not to be such a
ding-dong
so of course when i saw that range rover
story i was like oh
exactly exactly i i do
like you know relate to you i'm in like
a co-parenting dynamic
and i have been always inspired by
anyone who speaks
positively about co-parenting because
it makes us all feel like we're in this
wonderful club together
and thank you for always being so open
and inclusive about that because i think
it makes
us feel good that we're not alone
well thank you and you know i can't take
the credit i have
first my parents are my mom and my
dad and my stepdad are that
you know trilogy was just like the
ultimate because what they
embedded at us and what they showed us
and um
i don't think i understood how
mature and respectful and loving my
three parents were
until you put yourself in a similar
situation
and my dad and my stepdad were
i'm sure it definitely wasn't easy at
first the first couple years i don't
even know
if they spoke to one another but we
didn't know that because they never
talked
poorly about one another to us but i
know it was of course a challenge
for my mom to remarry and um
i'm sure for my dad it was a challenge
all of that but then
eventually my dad would come over once a
week for family dinners and my
dad and my stepdad would play golf with
one another about once a week and my dad
was over every christmas and so
i have them as examples and then i have
my sister courtney and my
i still call him my brother scott and so
much
so many great examples that
i don't think we allow one another to do
anything less than we get to learn from
one another and of course there's days
that
is definitely more trying and bumpy and
turbulent but you
never speak poorly about someone that
you have a child with or even an ex at
all like at some point you chose to be
in that relationship and at some point
there was love and respect
so why can't we at least find a common
ground somewhere
i everything you're saying i'm hanging
on every word
now i have i had my two daughters
because i felt this
karmic duty uh this destiny i wanted to
create for them like i never had
siblings and i always idealized them so
much
and even when they fight i'm like
whatever they're siblings um because all
my friends were siblings growing up
is it true that you want to have a
sibling for true
i do i do want to i you know i have so
many brothers and sisters
um so i do want to have
a sibling for true with the
world of covert i've been doing you know
ivf and all that kind of stuff and it's
been
more challenging in um a quarantined
year
but i definitely do
you